네. 안녕하세요. 오늘 여기 어디
사오 샤로 스길에 와 있습니다. 뒤에
[음악] 있는 건물주 분이 원래 저희
수강생님이었습니다. 원래 여기
1층에서 장사를 하셨었어요. 근데이
건물을 내가 매입하고 싶다라고
[음악] 해 가지고 저희가 이제
대출을 이용해서 보니까 정말
소액으로도 건물을 살 수 있더라고요.
[음악] 그래서이 건물을 진짜 보증금
정도의 금액으로 매입을 해 가지고
이렇게 사용 중에 있습니다. 직접
들어가서 매장도 좀 보면서 제가
건물주분 인터뷰를 해 보도록
하겠습니다. 가시죠.
건물주근을 모셨는데 간단하게 자기
소개 좀 부탁드릴게요.
>> 저는 주변뱅쿠바 운영하고 있는
원석이라고 합니다.
>> 자영업자분들이 되게 궁금해할 거
같아요. 건물을 일단 어떻게 매입하게
되는지가 되게 궁금하거든요.
>> 저는 이제 장사를 하고 있는 사람이다
보니까 불안정하게이 장사를 옮겨
다니면서 하는 것보다는 이곳을 더
안정적으로 하면 좋겠다. 물론 여러
물건지도 소개를 해 주셨지만 비교해
보다가 어 내가 영업하고 있는이
건물을 저는 매입하는게 제일 좋을 것
같습니다.라고 말씀드려서 그래서 같이
이렇게 구매하는 과정까지 흘러갔던
거죠. 뭐 제가 이제 앞전에도 얘기를
했지만 대출을 좀 잘 이용해 가지고
소액으로 좀 매입한 사례라고 저는
생각들거든요. 어느 정도 들으셨나요?
제가 그때 3억으로
일단 구매를 한 거고 저희 건물이
22억에 제가 매입을 했었잖아요.
보증금들도 건물 안에 깔려 있는
것들이 있었지만 그때 법인 대출로
저희가 80%까지 제가 갖고 있는
다른 부동사 하나를 추가 담보 걸어서
80%까지 대출도 다 받고 또 그
외에 보증금까지 다 하니까 실제로는
3억이 들었죠. 그래서 사실 3억이
어떻게 보면 매장하는데 인테리어 정도
금액으로 한 건데 사실 이게 [음악]
직접 쓴다 그러면 또 대출도 잘
나오거든요. 어떻게 보면은 지금
자영업자분들이 검을 매입하기 제일
좋은데 진짜 이렇게 소액으로 투자가
가능한지 모르시는 분들이 되게 많은
거 같아요. 사실 요즘에 임대가 좀
잘 안 되고 되게 문제가 많은데
어쨌든 나는 직접 채울 수도 있고
건물 매입하기에는 플레이어분들이
[음악] 제일 중요한 거 같고 어떻게
보면 그분들이 매입해야 되는 거 같고
건물의 스펙도 한번 좀 말씀해
주세요. 저희 건물은 대지는 좀
작아요. 36평, 옆면적은 이제
113평. 근데 거기에 확장된
합법부로 확장 공간까지 있거든요.
거의 한 125평 정도 나오죠.
>> 그러니까 사실 그 땅 대비해서는 진짜
풀로 채어진 그런 건물이지. 그때
이제 스터디 때도 이런 부분 되게
많이 보잖아요. 몇 %까지가 딱
허용이고 그거를 풀로 거의 다 채운
건물이 어떻게 보면은 가장 실속 있는
건물이니까
>> 그런 식으로 많이 비교해 봤을 때
저희 건물이 그게 진짜 잘 돼
있었어요.
>> 일단 지금 지하 1층이 지상 5층
건물이니까 가서 보시죠.
>> 네.
1층이 여기가 12평밖에 안 돼요.
>> 아,
>> 엄청 작은데 여기가 정말 장사가 잘
돼 가지고 건물 매입까지 할 수
있었던 저한테는 너무 소중한
>> 시대머니를 모을 수 있었던
>> 맞습니다. 오히려 그래서 막
장사하시는 분들이 작은 건물은 조금
피하실 수도 있는데 저 거꾸로 생각해
보면 큰 건물보다 리스크가 훨씬
적어요. 맞아요. 그러니까 사실
금건물 같은 경우에 인테리어 비용도
많이 들고 [음악] 그동안 뭐 이렇게
월세라든지 이런 것도 워낙 높아
가지고 좀 리스크가 되게 큰데 어떻게
보면 알짜가 되게 좋은 거 같아요.
>> 네. 작아야 운영하기가 효율적이
되니까 크면 클수록 인원도 많이
필요하고 인테리어 비용도 많이
올라가고 갖춰야 될게 많잖아요. 또
법적으로도 이제 넓은 건물은 뭐
소방법부터 시작해서 여러 가지 추가
비용이 계속 발생하는데 저희는 너무
작다 보니까 어떻게 보면 그런 부분에
있어서는 조금 더 혜택을 받을 수
있었죠. [음악] 지하도 한번가
보실까요?
>> 이쪽이 홀로 만들었고 안쪽은 이제
센트럴 키친이라 그래서 주방이 저희
위에 엄청 작거든요. 그래서 밑에서
공용 주방으로 같이 쓰고 있는 센트로
키치네요.
>> 아 이렇게.
>> 네. 외식업 하는 분들은 이런 공간이
있으면 좋아요.
>> 재료 선도 보관 측면에도 좋고 식제료
같은 것도 가격 변동이 심해질 때는
>> 저희가 매입을 해서 아예 쟁요. 그런
부분이 있습니다.
>> 근데 이제 이렇게 객단가 낮은 걸 해
보니까 수익성으로는 이게 별로 안
좋아서
>> 아
>> 그래서 지하를 케이터링으로 지금
뒤집고 다려고
>> 뒤집어 보니까 매출이 한 여섯 배
>> 빵 올라가더고여
>> 아 진짜요? 그 단가가 달라요.
>> 이층은 또 유명한 카페가 입점
있습니다.이 샤로스킬이 요런 톤의
가격들이 좀 귀해요.
>> 아, 작고 아담하면서 좀 여자분들이
좋아하시는 그런 감성이라서 서울대학교
학생분들 되게 많이 오십니다.
>> 그러니까 되게 아기자기하게
>> 그렇죠. 뭐 건물이 작다고 해도
분명히 채울 컨텐츠는 있습니다.
저희가 1층에 양식을 하고 있잖아요.
또 양식 손님들도 자연스럽게 올라와서
네.이 이 외식업 쪽은 이렇게 원투
펀치를 같이 잡아주면 너무 좋을 것
같아요.
>> 일단은 뭐 건물 좀 둘러봤는데 정말
알차게 잘 쓰고 계신 [웃음]
>> 감사합니다. 저도 이제 옆에서 보고
있지만 저도 기분이 좋아요. 그
사업도 너무 지금 잘되시고 계시고
예. 그래서 저도 되게 기분이 좋아서
혹시 이렇게 마지막으로 자영업자분들
아니면은 쓰시려는 분들이 좀 많이
보실 것 같아요. 그래서 그분들한테
하고 싶은 말 있으시면 좀 해 주시면
좋을 거요.
>> 일단은 너무 감사하게도 제 건물
매입하시는데 너무 큰 도움 주셨어
가지고 장사하시는 분들 중에 요식업
쪽 하신다면은 김윤수 대표님 통해서
저희한테 뭐 궁금하신 점 그런 거
물어보시면 제가 얼마든지 같이 좀
도와드리고 상담해 드릴 수 있거든요.
그런 것들
제일 중요한 거는 음식 장사하시는
분들은 꼭 자기 공간을 획득하셔
가지고 사업을 안정적으로 오래하셨으면
좋겠습니다. 그래야 건물 가치가
올라가고 그 건물 가치까지도
회소하시는게 저는 그게 진짜로 돈
버는 길이라고 생각해요.
>> 진짜 많은 도움이 될 거 같은데 정말
궁금한게 있으시다라고 하면 연락드리고
한번 물어보셔도
>> 네. 일단 오늘 영상은 여기까지
하겠습니다. 감사합니다.